[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here so i don't
know if you remember but the winningest
phone of my smartphone awards last year
was the asus rog phone 2 the spec king
so that thing won the best big phone of
the year that had the best battery life
of the year
and won the most improved award so how
do they follow it up
with this
this is the asus rog phone three so i've
been using and testing this phone
alongside the oneplus nord for a couple
weeks now and basically what you need to
know is it follows very closely in a lot
of the same footsteps as rog phone 2
similar design and specs and choices but
just bumped up a notch for 2020 and
really there are two incredible things
about this phone that continue to stick
out and that is the battery
and the specs so this design as you can
see it's kind of funny when i first saw
it i was like oh no
wait they're toning it down even more
remember the first rog phone was totally
wild the second rog phone was a little
toned down from that and so i saw this
third one and i got a little afraid they
might have started neutering the whole
gaming aesthetic to make it more of an
everyday phone but as soon as you pick
it up you quickly realize oh just
kidding this is absolutely 100 still a
super unique design that they've
committed to for this phone it's still
got the rgb lit logo at the back that
can glow for notifications still got the
traced lines and the little exposed slot
for the heat sink and the carbon chamber
cooling system on the side still has the
custom mappable air triggers on the side
which improved actually this year with
better sensitivity and precision and
more custom mapping options and it still
has even the offset usb-c port on the
bottom so you can charge while gaming
and the cable doesn't get in the way and
really above all it's still
absolutely huge it's just so massive
this is this is actually i think too big
a phone for me to want to carry it daily
and i really don't say that much i think
this this phone finally found that point
for me somewhere between the biggest
flagships of samsung and oneplus
we arrived at this and i think it's the
gigantic footprint that makes it too big
but you all know what it did win the
best big phone of the year for a reason
and a lot of that was how well they use
all this space so they kept the stereo
front-facing speakers in this phone and
they are actually incredible the stereo
image they produce and the volume they
achieve thanks to having all this space
is second to none some of the absolute
best speakers i've heard in a phone the
only thing is the volume curve i found
kind of weird like they really don't
start getting loud until you're at like
80 volume but that's not a huge deal
they can honestly fix that quickly with
a software update now again that
predecessor the rog phone 2 was that do
everything in one package phone and this
is still an incredible spec sheet and
we'll get to that in a second but it
does have a few things notably missing
this year first of all it doesn't have a
headphone jack built in on the rog phone
3.
there's also no official ip dust or
water resistance rating and there's also
no wireless charging probably because
they really wanted to keep that rgb
glowing logo on the back now the
headphone jack i was a little confused
by because it's a gaming phone and you
would still think someone who wants zero
lag
will accept nothing less than wired
audio but it also does come in the box
with this little accessory that gives
you usbc and a headphone jack on the
side so i guess it kind of makes up for
it but i do miss wireless charging in a
phone that i use every day just because
at this point
most phones i use and test have wireless
charging i have wireless chargers
everywhere so i do miss that all right
have a look
at this spec sheet
just just look at it i mean is there a
single thing on this list that isn't
absolutely bleeding edge top of the line
it's got the new snapdragon 865 plus
that's just starting to show up in
phones now by the way that chip is
clocked at up to 3.1 gigahertz in a
phone
16 gigs of ram it's a 1080p 144 hertz
oled display up to half a terabyte of
ufs 3.1 storage and a 6 000 milliamp
hour battery every single one of those
numbers is is the biggest or the highest
you can basically find or put in a phone
it's all top shelf parts but something
that i think a lot of people forget
is you also have to consider the best
way to transition from all those big
numbers
to actual user experience
is great software and asus software it's
okay to me it's getting better but it's
definitely not perfect
really there's a lot of subtle things
like animations and unlocking and
transitions and just occasional places
in the ui where it hiccups just a tiny
bit and i notice it now that's just me
and a lot of people haven't used a bunch
of other high-end high refresh rate
phones they may never notice this stuff
but most of the time this phone is super
smooth right up next to the other 144hz
phone i've used as the smoothest phone
i've ever tested so that's worth noting
and overall performance as you would
expect from that spec sheet has been
great and yes i did leave on 144 hertz
maxed out all the time because there
really isn't much of a downside right
you can this phone is going to let you
go between 60 90 120 and 144 hertz
i'll leave it maxed out because you
can't really hurt the battery much it's
so huge and it's only a 1080p screen so
the specs can clearly handle it so
yeah i paid for all the hurts might as
well use them
but
let's talk about that battery so this
phone again has a 6 000 milliamp hour
battery which is again the biggest
battery i've ever used in a phone
plus this year there's also 30 watt fast
charging supported and you guys already
know i've tested many other big phones
in the past thick boys like this
and none of them have actually gotten me
through two days you know some of them
get to the end of the day with like 40
left some of them will get a whole day
and a half but none of them have
actually really gotten me a comfortable
two days but i was i was testing this a
little while back and sure enough i had
a pretty light day
and i actually ended a day with 52
battery left at like 10 30 p.m
and when i saw that i was like wow i'm
ending the day with more than half my
battery
let's just try it let's just see if i
can go a full two days on this phone so
i didn't charge it i woke up the next
day and i went through an entire new day
and i got to the end of that day i think
at 9 30 p.m i had three percent battery
lift and it was about six hours of
screen on time so there was some gaming
and some navigation but two light days
in a row i made it to the end of the
second day
at 144 hertz that is
incredibly impressive again i mean i
expect nothing less from a just a huge
battery like that but two full days of
light use
easily over a day of heavy use at 144
hertz dude if you put this down to like
60 or 90 hertz just because you have a
long time where you're not gonna be able
to plug in
this is a legit two day phone and icing
on the cake is the fast charging too so
30 watts it might not seem super fast
but just think about this when you're
quick charging you get the fastest
charging speeds from about 0 to 60 65
before it levels off and you get closer
to full that's how batteries work well
when you're charging on this phone with
this huge battery the quick couple
minutes of charge from zero to sixty
five percent
just got you four thousand milliamp
hours
so charging is fast the battery lasts
forever you can use less charge cycles
so the battery stays healthy for longer
it's just all great and honestly it's
probably a lock again for the battery
award this year okay you got triple
cameras on the back um we all know we're
not buying a gaming phone for the
cameras none of them in the past have
had a good reputation for cameras but
didn't stop me from testing it and my
findings lined up probably exactly what
you'd expect pretty mediocre set of
cameras so you have a 64 megapixel main
camera it's a big number and then a 13
megapixel ultra wide and a 5 megapixel
macro camera to me this macro camera in
a gaming phone is the perfect example of
just adding the cheapest extra camera to
just be able to say you have triple
cameras but honestly i really don't
think people are looking to just buy the
phone with more cameras
dear smartphone manufacturers if you
have the choice between adding a bad
macro camera or one that people won't
very often use
or just not adding it
you can just not add it so shots from
the main camera are passable when you
give it enough light so daytime shots
are fine but as soon as you get into
those tougher situations like with
higher dynamic range or just low light
in general they definitely fall apart
and the ultra wide and macro are just
much softer no matter how good the light
is i mean they did their job the
ultrawide is definitely very wide it's
125 degrees and the macro lens does in
fact close focus but let's not get
carried away people aren't buying this
phone for the cameras i'm actually more
confused why there's still a camera bump
on the back of the phone
at all on maybe the thickest flagship
phone of the year surely they could have
fit the cameras into the chassis with no
bump but i guess not all these features
and all these specs packed into this
phone had me reconsidering like the
original question when we first started
getting these gaming phones which is
does it make sense
to make to buy a gaming phone and i
think the answer for a really small
group of people
is yes people that play a lot of
well-optimized games on their phone and
want the best possible experience for
that
will enjoy this phone and things like
air triggers and the faster refresh rate
and the snappier response time of the
display and the gaming specific features
like x mode
that throttles up the cpu and game genie
that lets you you know feature hub for
stuff like recording the screen and
silencing notifications and clearing out
ram for a little bit of extra
performance all that stuff for that tiny
group of people
sure but for the rest of us these really
just end up being
glorified or really nice
media machines media consumption
phones
big screen big speakers big battery high
refresh
like watching videos scrolling instagram
like this is an amazing phone for that
and that's fine too but for those who
really know what they're getting into
rog phone 3
is a beast of a phone
so that's been it
thanks for watching and thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video so
in a previous video i mentioned that
expressvpn is more trustworthy because
they run their servers in ram but what
does that actually mean well when you
use the internet like normal your isp
your internet service provider so
comcast verizon whoever it is routes
your data to whatever sites you're
visiting but see the problem is because
all that information is going through
your isp every time and they can store
logs on all that stuff in the us they're
legally allowed to sell that data but
when you're using expressvpn you're
rerouting your traffic through the
expressvpn encrypted servers so the isp
can only see that you're communicating
with the vpn server and not any of the
websites you're visiting or what you're
doing online now you might be thinking
that's nice but now the vpn can just log
all of what i'm doing online and that's
smart to think many vpns claim to have a
no log policy but expressvpn's trusted
server technology means they're the
first vpn to engineer all their servers
to only run in ram so they can't retain
logs even by accident because the
machines reset on every reboot and
expressvpn is so confident in their no
logs claim that they've even had pwc
come in and audit their technology so
it's kind of a no-brainer for all of us
to be using expressvpn so if you haven't
gotten on the train yet you can join the
link is in the description
expressvpn.com
mkbhd will get you an extra three months
free
so there you go a little extra for you
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace